It does happen. Of course there's happy marriages.
Things work out. Sometimes it does work out.
I'm just saying that's not the norm.
That's not, you know,
that is
those one off success stories that everyone is trying to cling to,
pretending like that could be their reality.
So for the people that it does work out for,
I'm super happy for you. Genuinely,
genuinely, like,
that's beautiful. I love love.
I'm happy that love exists.
I'm happy that love is real.
I know for me, sometimes it.
It doesn't matter that it's been 25 years.
I've met women. I was a bartender.
I met women that were married for 28 years,
and it fell apart. 35 years,
and then it fell apart. So until these people, like,
truly take their last breath,
and after they're gone,
there's no ugly stories of the second family that the dad had
or whatever the fuck, you know,
I'm here for it. I love it.
I encourage it. It's great.
That's not that usually how it turns out.
Most relationships end.
I've never had a relationship that lasted forever.
I've never, you know,
that's never been my reality.
I've never seen it in anybody.
The people that I know that have lasted their whole
entire life and died together,
they weren't happy. So,
um, you know, sometimes.
Sometimes
when I hear women talking about their marriage and how happy they are,
I mean, they're describing the same kind of marriage.
I meant, I Was in.
They're just okay with it.
Some of the women that I've talked to that have.
That have these long lasting relationships,
they are still oblivious to the shitty parts of their own life.
They're just okay with it.
You know what I mean? Like,
even a pig likes to swim in shit.
So there are some people that like it,
and they're therefore. And for whatever reason,
if you're happy, you're happy,
and I'm happy for you, I'll share in that happiness.
I just, um,
have a strong, burning feeling inside that more often than not,
that's not the case.